having a first kiss what is more special
to you if it happens spontaneously In
the Heat of the Moment or if the guy
asks permission first
oh my God spontaneous spontaneous yes
spontaneous okay what does that say
about Tripoli leaves
she drinks a four local that's all you
gotta know about her
no they're gonna cancel me I didn't have
to catch the five there's a five okay
let me ask you what determines what
should and should not be spontaneous
during sex
if you're ugly don't even think don't
even try anything simultaneous if you've
talked about it at least like
before this girl the middle girl is so
stoned that yeah she couldn't even open
her eyes I was gonna say she's kind of
funny she's she's on Mars
what I feel like yeah I'm a big person
I'm just filming Vibe if you don't feel
the vibe and if you don't understand
social cues and maybe you should just
wait and ask for consent okay does no
always mean no yes no always means no
okay
um if consent is such an important thing
why don't they typically ask for it in
Hollywood movies
because it's stigmatized to not be like
not be sexy to not be the move it's not
stigmatized it's just weird
publicity goes with
you said a whole lot of male perspective
okay
those Hollywood movies are taken from
the male perspective so they don't
really get that women want to be asked
like that don't wow
yeah everything is from the whole world
kisses a woman who's unconscious
he doesn't ask for her consent right but
that was the only way for Sleeping
Beauty to be awake okay all right what
determines what should and should not be
spontaneous during sex
consent literally like just asking for
consent all the time
okay so so every time a guy like puts
his hand somewhere he needs to ask
permission for it
I think that or just ask if you're
comfortable with it yeah it's all about
you comfortable with me you know putting
my hands on your waist or something and
checking in I think that checking in you
don't necessarily have to ask every
single time but just checking in and
making sure that the person is
comfortable with what's going on is like
a really big deal establish ground rules
there's nothing wrong every
communication is key right not one of
these girls sex does he need to have a
pre-production meeting about it yes yes
okay and uh that is not something you
just oh
sorry babe wrong hole is consent
something that can be withdrawn once
it's given
yes I think so
of course maybe not but I feel like if
someone comes in is like yeah let's do
this but then halfway like they're
getting into it and they haven't done it
and they're like oh wait I don't I'm not
sure about this I think you can at any
point stop like you should once you
start you shouldn't be forced to like
yeah I agree with that but it's also
pretty obvious as it as like someone
else like if you start if you gave
consent first it's like you should have
known like you should have really
thought about it or I was like why'd you
give consent like it's kind of like oh
why did you stop oh so we're so this
girl is saying like if somebody changes
their mind halfway through the girl on
the right is saying you just you just
play you just plow through and keep you
know forcing it on someone because they
already said yes they're not allowed to
change their mind that's just asinine
thing that can be withdrawn what would
be the point of asking permission in the
first place
I think it's yeah that's valid yeah I
think it needs it shouldn't just be a
lightweight question at the end of the
day when you're with a guy like you
might
think
of him in one's way like maybe at the
beginning of the night and you can be
more comfortable with him and then as
the night progresses maybe there's red
flags that come off it gives he gives me
eggs he gives me X have you heard of an
X when someone makes you feel icky it's
like when they do something and it's
like it's an ick cringy it's yeah it's
like cringy but it's like an instant
turn off where it's like they do that
one thing and it's over girls all have
them apparently maybe you changed your
mind and that's completely fine yeah
everyone that would mean that consent
would be withdrawn and if you're going
to say like I'm not comfortable anymore
then consent's not given anymore but I
actually actually do agree with you I
think that it is something that should
be able to be withdrawn a big old
Slurpee but here's my question is there
a difference between withdrawing consent
during and after the ACT yes
I think if you're doing it after the ACT
like after it's all done you'd be like
oh I didn't give consent but you
actually did I think that's where the
issues occur like I think if you're in
the middle of it you can withdraw but
after you finish that I feel like you
can't say like yeah that's more regret
that's not even like oh I didn't give
consent that's regret like oh crap I did
it and didn't want to type thing a lot a
lot of us girls are nervous too every
situation is different I don't know this
is just such generalization this is a
stupid question and a stupid
conversation with stupid people with
stupid girls stupid questions in a
stupid place things happen I don't think
that it's okay either way I mean I I
think that like
you know if they're withdrawing consent
like whatever the guy is doing is not
okay either way if the woman is
uncomfortable whether or not said
anything if a man consents to sex does
that mean he's consenting to potentially
becoming a father
well if he was smart he would use all
the protection and not he would do
everything in his power to not be the
father right
um
I think it's a if it's happens it's a
consequence of him making the decision
of having sex okay if they if a woman
consents to sex does that mean she's
consented checkmate
no I think it's the same thing yeah I
think yeah if you're doing it there's
you know there's a risk of it if you
take every precaution you can and
whatever happens happens so why is the
man often blamed for getting a woman
pregnant AKA knocking her up when it
actually takes two people
that's tough I think it's just another
stereotype yeah I agree okay yeah like
um don't women ultimately get to decide
who has sex absolutely is that a thing
that men are blamed for getting women
pregnant I feel like that's how it is a
lot of the time you don't think so no
but that's also do it that way
it is like the Dual responsibility yeah
it's also with the woman it's like if
she's young it's like you know what I
mean like that's how people see it I
could be wrong I don't know well yeah I
mean we've talked about that a lot how
you know women's I mean I feel like they
lower their value if they say the
responsibilities just put on the man so
it's like no [ __ ] it's [ __ ] yeah
it is they're not together then it's
like the dude if you're about to sleep
with a guy and you are very worried
about getting pregnant and you're not
and you know you're not taking birth
control or you don't have an IUD and you
want him to you know put on a suit you
make sure that you bring it and insist
on it don't say well he didn't so I
didn't say anything yeah you know that's
just as much your fault yeah I mean come
on I'm so sick of everybody passing the
buck on responsibility whether it be
about pregnancy or STDs or money or jobs
or anything everything is somebody
else's fault I know it's so funny I love
that I love that like even Tate's
reference he's like if I get struck by
lightning it was somehow my fault and
it's such a good analogy because if you
take personal accountability for
everything even stuff like that which
the normal person wouldn't think is your
own fault and they think it's just bad
luck then everything's in your control
at the end of the day because every
decision you make leads you up to that
one point you know what I mean like
literally everything you do there were
some things that happened you know like
you God forbid you're a someone's best
friend or child yeah it could get you
know hit by a bus across town when
you're not even there that is a horrible
thing that is happening in your life so
that it's not your responsibility or you
know you have no personal responsibility
for that unless yeah but if it's your
kid you could have taught them to better
look up for cars or something like it's
stuff like that though [ __ ] happens no I
know but I'm saying like you can at
least take that level of personal it's
just like a mind oh no that's blame it's
just then that's blaming there's a
difference between taking personal
responsibility and in blaming yourself
unreasonable belief or things that have
yeah but you don't have to kill yourself
over it you can just recognize that
there's stuff you can do to get the life
you want and to mitigate stuff that you
don't want to happen yeah if two drunk
people
how do you know around the advantage of
who if neither one could offer
responsible consent
it's not consenting on either on either
yeah
neither party was able to
uh sober these people just go by the
Instagram stories whatever they see if
you had Marta then two drinks and you
can't technically consent and it's rape
like have you ever been anywhere I tell
you if you meet a girl and she's been
drinking no I know you know I just I
know it could all be tempting but do not
do not bother because she can wake up
the next day and say I was drunk and I
did not consent even if she mauled you
you know I I can't take it with these
young girls nothing is their fault
nothing is their responsibility if they
have a regret it is somebody else's
fault [ __ ] yeah well they don't have
regrets with me they just I drop them
and then they're so Shattered by the
fact that I that didn't keep them in my
presence right right I know they're
filling up my DMs so please talk to your
son for me please tell somebody to text
me back please tell Sunny to text me
back yes so therefore
then I just have to break their hearts
out whatever happens happens
unfortunately
aren't most sexual encounters happening
under
your influence like like most of them
so so that's kind of a problem right
yeah if you put yourself in a situation
where you
where you hook up with someone and you
don't remember anything and then try to
accuse it as being ripped that is not
right that's why you should always have
friends around you exactly you've seen
that we trust around you yeah but when
girls get drunk they're so I see it all
the time especially at College like
they're such idiots
I was that girl in college two drinks in
and me running out the bar or like
running like losing my friends it's like
you guys are such idiots we had one
friend who would drink and kind of like
to the point of being blacked out and
would disappear and that was really
scary for us just annoying it's scary
it's scary as girls it's very scary but
you know when someone drinks to the
point of blacking out they just become
another person all together so that's a
whole other question it is you are
another person really it's not yourself
you can't really point fingers in that
situation yeah okay but who's typically
blamed in that situation the man the man
okay is that fair no not really no okay
so why aren't false accusations taken
more seriously when there's plenty of
scenarios where it's not necessarily
just the man's fault because the walk
agenda because Society sees men as very
masculine or masculine yeah over women
so they see
Advantage but I think that's just
another stereotype another
Trend that's always seen as like the man
being the stronger dominant
no it's because they don't teach women
to have personal accountability that's
literally all it is oh you you don't
know if you consented or you regret it
oh it's totally his fault it's all the
man's fault you didn't have him you
didn't have a brain and a decision to
not go out to a bargain trunk go back
with the guy go to bed with like you're
such a dumbass you're a dumbass no
you're 100 right I wasn't really
listening to what she said but I agree
with everything you just said the
stereotypical nice guy and the
stereotypical bad boy
uh this the stereotypical nice guys like
he always gets ignored and he gets swept
under the rug and he's just like he's
the I asked for a hug type of person oh
the bad boy like he gets [ __ ] and
he opened to the car door I love how
do you want why do you think we have the
expression nice guys finish last
um because a lot of people like Overlook
they're like if you have a friend and
he's like so sweet too and you might not
think that he is your uh would like go
for him like that then you might just
like look over him oh he's just a friend
but really he's the person who would
like always like treat you the way you
wanted to be treated
even if they're like kind of a pushover
a little bit I think women definitely
like dominance okay well where do women
find attractive about a bad boy
the dominance
that might come with like emotional
abuse and like stuff like that but like
so a lot of women like to be dominated
bad boys are just bad boys they just
they're hot I don't know okay
um why do we have the expression nice
guys finish last
uh
probably because they take too long like
to
um secure the bag I guess to secure the
girl but with bad boys they're just like
I want this Kate is so right about that
I mean I feel like girls do just like
drama and you know Randomness and not
being able to have full control over you
like at the end of the day that's what
they do really like yeah like and well
in high school I only liked nice guys
but I never ever had dates I never had a
boyfriend in high school or anything and
I only liked nice guys and I would go
out on dates with bad guys because you
know the cute bad boy asked like he's
cute no one else is asking the guy
really have a crush on isn't coming
around go out with the bad guy and just
go out on a couple dates and I just
always bailed out because they just
moved too fast for me too and I wanted
nice guys and uh so I thank God didn't
go down that bad boy path in high school
I mean not that I never did get involved
with any later on in life but I think of
a young girl
I find attractive about a bad boy
[Music]
um
you know like gang and gang stuff like I
you know I don't know like just like
having a good time like not really
worried about any of the stupid [ __ ] how
do bad boys treat women
I had every opportunity to hang out with
guys who were like you know I went to
drugs and crime and all that I had those
opportunities growing up in a you know
like a blue-collar neighborhood where it
was split down the middle with the types
of people we had around and I just every
time I was around a guy like that I was
like I couldn't get out of there fast
enough and I didn't feel safe I didn't
feel excited or interested in hanging I
don't know maybe it was just me I was a
late bloomer too as far as the whole boy
thing went yeah I've never gotten more
girls when my game plan was be a
gentleman and and act like I don't care
never never been easier in my entire
that's what you're saying just be a
gentleman and act like and be it
different it was a legit joke I I can't
tell I don't know what are you trying to
say no I'm saying like it was it was it
was so easy it was like the first couple
weeks of college you're saying being an
indifferent gentleman and that works
yeah just like if a girl is like we'd
hang out in my roommate's room and
there'd be a bunch of girls and I'd grab
a chair from my room and I would just do
it and then I'd go sit down in my own
spot and I just you know I I wouldn't
like make moves on girls because it's
always like when you're going after
girls you're going out and you're like
we're gonna get girls it never it just
doesn't happen then so I think the key
is indifference so you don't have to be
a bad boy you don't have to be a jerk
you just have to have an air of
indifference and but be polite and be
kind and be a gentleman it's the same
thing with like sales it's a lot easier
to sell a deal if you're indifferent
you're like well we're choosing to work
with you you know it's like if you don't
work with us we'll get another client it
doesn't matter it's the same thing with
girls but if you're like desperate
that's why they don't go after the
little Geeks you know because it's like
they don't have opportunities like that
but if a guy is higher value and he has
a bunch of opportunities then you want
to jump on him more so what is the
difference between withdrawing consent
and regretting sex
um there is no withdrawing consent
that's not a thing
after okay obviously if in the middle
you're like this I don't want to do this
it's like okay and then you stop like
what kind of normal dude doesn't do that
like it's just it's just it's just weird
questions you know what I mean it's like
obviously if the girl's like stop it's
not like nope you already said yes like
that's just it's just a weird question
it's not comfortable it just wasn't for
you
[Music]
continue and if he does well then that's
not right and regret might be like
regret might be like you felt that
uncomfortableness and you really weren't
having a good time but you just didn't
say anything and you just waited for it
to be over that could be regret like God
I wish I had just stopped it sooner but
still it's a matter of personal
responsibility I mean if you regret it
then you regret it but I feel like we
have nights that are just like Ugh like
I regret hanging out with that guy like
I don't maybe yeah I've had that with
girls too they happen but like
do you think we're headed towards
needing consent contracts for sex
go on the planet good luck with that
yeah
No One's Gonna Be Like comes on my
contract yeah
right it does definitely take a lot of
the the romance out of it but believe it
or not they've actually come out with
apps for uh consent
who are these Duds who are these people
that are so oh yeah study no it's
annoying they've got to have an app
I've seen like the papers where you need
both hand prints on them or whatever but
it was one thing to have a conversation
for sure but but to have to have the
lawyers involved in your in your bedroom
if any guy ever came to at me like that
I'd be like you know what thank you so
much for showing me who you are go to
hell said it best he's like what I tell
my daughter if God forbid something like
that happened and you don't want to go
to the police at least go to the doctors
and get DNA done so that there's
evidence in case you ever do want to go
to the police that makes so much more
sense than just 25 years later you're
like you touched me when I
yeah I don't like all these these very
late coming
accusations excuse me it is what it is I
understand it's extremely difficult for
women to come forward and there's a lot
of complicated reasons why women don't
but what do you even get at it like I'm
sorry but like 25 years later
yeah like I've had bad stuff happen to
me and it's like you gotta move on like
what other choice do you have like I
know it sounds bad but like like what
else are you gonna do then just move on
you're gonna go to court and do all this
[ __ ] 20 years later for what like what
happens I don't know I don't know I
don't get it either and it's not like
you had evidence or anything you're just
going to court and accusing the dude
yeah if you were I don't like I don't
know maybe I don't like it either that's
gonna give me I don't like it either if
you did sign with one would you still be
able to withdraw consent
because then you kind of be like you
know it's in writing you know what I
mean yeah you got to read the small font
if the paper says like you can't respond
you sign then and my question is also
you know if if you could withdraw
consent after you sign a contract why
are we still using contracts that's true
yeah I agree I mean how else would it be
possible to hold anyway this makes me
want to flip a table I can't even
believe that we're out of people we're
having this conversation
on consent and I don't think that that
that there's a lot of funding in that
and I think that what she wants to put
funding into consent education everyone
every teach your own children because
the government doesn't belong in our
bedrooms they used to teach us sex ed
sex ed was was just about literally
about science it was about health this
goes here this is how baby happens these
diseases can get transmitted you know
now I there was a video of a guy like
talking about how in his class he had
somebody come in and was showing all the
kids and I'm talking kids like butt
plugs and dildos and vibrators like
we're not what who the hell is a teacher
to teach a child about like sexual
pleasure and kink and and his own things
that he likes to do in the bedroom who
the hell are you it was just a
scientific thing that is for the parents
to teach and that is for you know
children to grow and experience and
learn in their own time you know some 13
year olds are already got God forbid
like they are already having sex some 13
year olds are still sleeping with
stuffed animals I mean and they they
don't that conversation doesn't belong
in the classroom yeah are you looking at
me like that for really makes me mad I
find it I think it's abusive I think
it's a borderline pedophilia to talk to
Children about all the Leisure parts and
all the things
too many God people any God they need
them bad they need a lot of God they
really do it's really scary but they
really do I mean and people will be like
you and your God and they [ __ ] all over
people who believe in God but look at
look at what happens without it look at
what the world looks like without it
this was not fun it was not fun to watch
however many minutes of dumb people on
the street that's what I think but if it
was fun to watch maybe we had some good
reactions thank you so much for watching
make sure to follow myself on Instagram
at sunnyvaz I'll see you later
[Music]
[Music]